I do think Russia Cena has a bit of a
problem at the moment in the sense that
it might be coverage it might be the MPS
but the past few weeks I felt a little
bit loose in terms of
um some cabinet ministers speaking out
with speeches some Tory MPS kind of
freelancing with their views on policy
and they get a lot of attention because
virtually cnx government isn't saying as
much and all together when you can buy
an opportunity you know these Anonymous
briefings about has some Boris Johnson
MPS are going to obstruct vicious
Premiership is just creating a very
messy picture of the Tory party which I
think is the last thing where she
students if he is going to have a chance
of turning things around